wir stehen an eurer seite hat so beiden
ebenfalls gesagt war ein klares zeichen
an polen das ist das was ich ihnen
vorher schon angekündigt habe die klare
unterstützung das hat er auf jeden fall
ausgesprochen wladimir putin ist schuld
punkt ausrufezeichen hat joe biden
gesagt noch mal eine klare anklage nach
dem was er heute schon in diesem
statement deswegen vorhin ja auch
gezeigt haben gesagt hat als er wladimir
putin nach seinem vor seinem treffen mit
dem polnischen staatspräsidenten als er
wladimir putin als schlächter bezeichnet
hat da gibt es übrigens schon reaktionen
aus moskau da heißt es aus moskau das
würde den beziehungen nicht gut tun na
gut und am ende hat der beiden gesagt
niemals aufgeben so sieht's aus dann
ordnen wir das ganze doch gerne nochmal
ein zusammen mit professor andreas
heinemann grüder
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität bonn und ost experte hat
professor
guten abend was ist das für eine rede
aus ihrer sicht gewesen
es ist eine rede die deutlich macht das
geht hier um eine system
auseinandersetzung es geht nicht um nato
es geht nicht um einflusssphären es geht
nicht um die sicherheit russland sondern
wir sind in einer neuen system
auseinandersetzen so vater hat er
angeknüpft eigentlich an die rolle auch
des papstes an die solidarisch an den
fall der mauer das heißt er hat deutlich
gemacht wir haben es hier auf der einen
seite mit demokratie mit regelbasierter
internationaler ordnung mit freiheit der
wahl zu tun und auch bei anderen seite
mit autokratie diese
auseinandersetzungen wird dauern das
heißt sie wird nicht nur
militärisch auszutragen sein sondern es
geht letztlich um die fähigkeit des
russischen regimes zu überleben und
diesem regime hat eine kampfansage
erteilt und deutlich gemacht wir werden
diesen kampf mit dem politischen mit der
putin schon autokratie bis zum schluss
führen das war in dem sinne einer
kampfansage an das mutige politische
regime war das aus ihrer sicht der
profession brüder etwas neues war es
etwas anderes als das was wir in den
letzten tag ich würde fast sagen und
wochen doch schon gehört haben
er hat den konflikt in eine andere
dimension hinein gehoben weil es
eigentlich bisher darum ging stehen wir
als nato der ukraine bei und sind wir
als nato geschlossen das hat er alles
noch mal neu bekräftigt dabei hat den
fundamentalen charakter dieser
auseinandersetzung deutlich gemacht es
gibt eigentlich nicht um
nato auf der einen seite und russlands
sicherheitsinteressen auf bayern seite
sondern es geht um die freiheit der wahl
es geht letztlich darum dass sie die
auseinandersetzungen von der wir meinten
1989 wäre sie beendet gewesen dass wir
vor dieser auseinandersetzung erneut
stehen sofern ich halte die rede
durchaus für fundamental und zweitens
denke ich es war das erste mal eine rede
wohl jemand auch von den westlichen
führern emotional sich mit der ukraine
sehr stark solidarisiert hat leider hat
beiden entscheidende fragen allerdings
auch nicht angesprochen nämlich die
frage wann wird dieser konflikt
eigentlich zu unserem eigenen auch
militärischen konflikt das heißt wo sind
rote linien das hat darum shift das ist
ja dass er in das ich vorher auch gesagt
habe dass ich in den letzten zwei wochen
die ich in den usa war dort auch immer
wieder gehört habe das ist wirklich in
den usa keine einzige stimme gab
zumindest die ich wahrgenommen habe die
irgendwie in die richtung eines in
wolfen uns wie man das in den usa nennt
eine einbezug eben in den krieg
irgendwie ginge ist das nicht das große
dilemma das eben tatsächlich hier ein
krieg vor der tür
stattfindet und die nato eigentlich
nicht reingezogen werden möchte das
heißt sie stellt die rote linie
zumindest so dass senator mitglieder
angegriffen werden dann würde man anders
reagieren aber bis dahin bleibt es eben
bei nur in anführungszeichen sanktionen
ja insofern
gibt es dieses missverhältnis zwischen
der rhetorik und den taten seit geraumer
zeit man fragt sich ist die ukraine
heute in einer situation als polen 1939
oder wie wäre das eigentlich im falle
israels würden werde genauso sagen ist
ja kein nato-mitglied wäre das dann auch
noch starts saison oder eine rhetorik
ich finde die
vermeintlich scharfe grenze liegen
inzwischen artikel von
selbstverteidigung der nato-mitglieder
und und ukraine ist in wirklichkeit gar
nicht so klar zu ziehen was passiert zum
beispiel wenn russen
munitions konvois oder waffennachschub
aus nato staaten angreifen was passiert
in dem falle wo sie biochemische waffen
einsetzen und der fallout davon auch
nato staaten betrifft was passiert wenn
die russen taktische atomwaffen in der
ukraine einsetzen was passiert wenn sie
akw s angreifen und die radioaktive
wolke nicht an der ukrainisch polnischen
grenze
stopp macht was passiert wenn sie jetzt
einmal steht da wie man opel und weitere
auch noch auslöschen würden wir zum
beispiel humanitärer konvois von den
beiden auch sprach also der humanitäre
zugänge würden wir die auch schützen
oder würden wir wie im falle srebrenica
sagen oder nicht unsere baustelle also
hier werden viele kritische fragen
eigentlich nach wie vor umgangen und es
kann durchaus sein dass die nato
in konflikt nicht vor der eigenen
haustür halten kann apropos eigene
haustür ich versuche es noch mal anders
ich finde es sehr interessant dieses
gespräch mit ihnen joe biden war gestern
ja an der grenze also 80 kilometer 90
kilometer entfernt von der ukrainischen
grenze in polen noch jetzt kommt gerade
eben die meldung vor 50 minuten 18 uhr
soll es einen schweren luftangriff
gegeben haben an der westseite der
ukraine in lewis dort soll ein
treibstofflager angegriffen worden seien
noch mal die frage wo ist denn aus ihrer
sicht die rote linie und vielleicht habe
ich immer in der letzten frage auch ein
fehler gemacht ist die rote linie denn
eindeutig wenn
ein nato land angegriffen wird wenn die
bomben also noch ein paar kilometer
weiter westlich von lewis landen
irgendwo auf polnischem terra dann wird
militärisch geantwortet von der nato
das ist das versprechen dass beiden
abgibt dass die nato abgegeben und
trotzdem ist nach wie vor unklar in
welcher form würden sie denn dann
reagieren würde das dann der begrenzte
reaktion seien würden sie dann sagen
nein wir verteidigen jetzt auf das nato
gebiet
jenseits sozusagen der grenze weil die
schüsse kamen ja von russischen waffen
aus ukrainischer richtung würden wir
dann also auch auf russische positionen
auf dem territorium der ukraine schießen
und so weiter sind eine fülle von fragen
letztlich ungeklärt ich würde mal sagen
wir können gerade weil sie die
eskalationsgefahr enorm hoch ist
nach wie vor schneller in diesen
konflikten auch hineingezogen werden als
wir denken und es gibt dann eben nicht
nur um
selbstverteidigung
vor einem direkten angriff der russen
meines erachtens müssen wir deutlich
machen putin mario pohl
das ist jetzt geschehen aber wenn es in
weiteren fällen zu einer entsprechenden
auslöschung von städten kommt mit
auslösung von massenflucht also ist ja
auch nicht so dass die massenflucht nach
europa nur ein ukrainisches problem ist
wir sind betroffen davon wir können ja
nicht sagen und wie bei zehn millionen
sind wir nicht betroffen irgendwann ist
unsere sicherheit davon betroffen unsere
kosten sind davon betroffen also wir
müssen deutlich machen putin hier sind
die grenzen und wenn du diese letzten
überschreitest dann wird es auch
reaktionen geben die er dann
respektieren wird vielleicht dann noch
mal die zahlen die vereinten nationen
schätzen eine brüder das 3,7 millionen
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
geflüchtet sind seit beginn der des
krieges durch russland am 24 februar vor
über einem monat
2,2 millionen davon sollen durch polen
gekommen sein viele können weiter
gereist sein da gibt es aber offenbar
keine zeit da haben wir heute aber dann
doch was gelernt von der polnischen
regierung die hat nämlich sagt jeder
ukraine und jene ukrainerin die in polen
bleiben möchte darf auch hier bleiben
das sind zumindest man neue töne in
sachen flüchtlingspolitik aus polen
nicht mit bezug auf die ukraine aber
wenn wir uns die letzten jahre anschauen
zum abschluss nochmal diese rede
professor grüne der blick noch einmal
auf diese rede von joe biden noch einmal
zum abschluss sie sagen es ist eine neue
richtung weil es hier um etwas
generelles geht gerne nochmal das auf
dunkel braucht zum abschluss wo sie hier
dieses besondere sehen
also beiden bekennt sich ganz groß im
unterschied zu trump zu der europäischen
verantwortung der usa er knüpft
eigentlich sogar an an die rolle im
zweiten weltkrieg und seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg das heißt es nicht mehr
america first sondern wir sind mit den
europäern zusammen in einem sicherheits
verschwinden ist das heißt wir hier
trennen nicht mehr zwischen
touristischer europäische sicherheit
dass sie ganz neue aussagen zweitens ob
die usa übernehmen die verantwortung
nach wie vor für die europäische
sicherheit und insbesondere auch in der
nato und delegieren sie wieder an die eu
noch an irgendwie europäische autonomie
das heißt die usa treten quasi in die
rolle wieder ein die sie bis 1989 90 in
europa hatten das ist ein sehr
machtvolles bekenntnis mal sagen
professor andreas heinemann grüder
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität bonn und ost experte vielen
dank ihnen für die einschätzung hier
direkte läuft nach der rede von arbeiten